FORWARD.
>> THIS YEAR HAS BEEN LIKE THE
1918.
IT'S 1928, '29 MEETS 1968.
SO YOU'VE HAD A GREAT PANDEMIC.
YOU'VE HAD ECONOMIC UNREST.
AND YOU'VE HAD THE UNTETHERING
OF A COUNTRY ALONG THE LINES OF
RACE, SIMILAR TO '68.
BUT WE HAD ALL OF THOSE MOMENTS
IN ONE YEAR.
>> FOR ME, PERSONALLY, I WAS --
I WAS ALREADY IN THIS REALLY RAW
SPACE.
YOU KNOW?
I WAS ROCKED BY BRIANNA TAYLOR
AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT DO YOU DO?
RIGHT?
WHAT DO WE DO?
AND I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
ASKING THAT SAME QUESTION AND
THEN GEORGE FLOYD IS MURDERED.
AND, ALL OF A SUDDEN, LIKE, THE
WORLD AWAKENS.
>> WATCHING MY DAUGHTER GO OUT
AND PROTEST IN THE STREETS.
YOU KNOW, MY DAUGHTER IS 15
YEARS OLD.
SHE WILL BE 16 SOON.
AND IT WAS SUCH A CONFLICTING
MOMENT.
IT WAS A MOMENT OF TENSION FOR
ME BECAUSE I WAS SO EXCITED THAT
SHED THE WHEREWITHAL AND WANT TO
GO OUT WITH HER MASK ON AND A
SIGN THAT SAID HER LIFE MATTERS.
ON THE FLIP SIDE I WAS SO
HEARTBROKEN AND SAD THAT MY
DAUGHTER COULDN'T BE LIKE -- SHE
HAS TO WEAR A SIGN REAFFIRMING
HER HUMAN DIGNITY AND HER HUMAN
HUMANITY.
>> SOMETIMES PEOPLE GIVE THEIR
LIVE, YOU KNOW, THEY WANT TO
GIVE THEIR LIFE FOR A CAUSE.
WHILE GEORGE FLOYD'S MURDER
CAUSED THE REVOLUTION, HE DIDN'T
GIVE HIS LIFE.
HIS LIFE WAS TAKEN FROM HIM.
WHEN YOU HAVE TIME TO SIT AN
DIGEST THINGS, THEY HAVE A
BIGGER EFFECT ON YOU.
I'M WATCHING THE NEWS AND
THINKING THERE IS NO WAY A MAN
IS BEING KILLED ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
LIKE THIS IS A MURDER.
>> I THINK THAT WE SOMETIMES GET
CONFUSED AND I WANT PEOPLE TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND THIS.
THE DATABASE OF GEORGE FLOYD --
THE CASE OF DEREK CHAUVIN WAS
NOT JUSTICE.
IT WAS ACCOUNTABLE.
>> COLIN KAEPERNICK JUST SIMPLY
KNELT DOWN TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
REALITY OF POLICE KILLING OF
UNARMED BLACK MEN AND THE
RESPONSE TO HIM AND THE
VILIFICATION AND ISOLATION AND
THE REJECTION.
NOW JUST TWO YEARS LATER, LOOK
WHERE WE ARE.
>> THINK ABOUT HOW MORE THAN AN
ATHLETE BECAME A THING.
SOMEONE TOLD LeBRON JUST TO SHUT
UP AND DRIBBLE.
>> WHO IS ANYBODY TO TELL THESE
ATHLETES THAT THEY CAN'T SPEAK
UP ON THESE SOCIAL ISSUES?
IT'S COMING FROM THEIR HEARTS.
IT'S COMING NATURALLY.
>> WNBA PLAYERS AND SOME OF THE
WOMEN'S NATIONAL TEAM, SOCCER
PLAYERS, ATHLETES FROM ALL
SPORTS SPEAKING UP AND MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
IT'S IMPORTANT.
>> I WAS SO HAPPY THAT THERE
WERE CONVERSATIONS AROUND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD SIT
OUT, THE NBA SHOULD SIT OUT IN
THE AFTERMATH OF GEORGE FLOYD,
AND WHEN THEY DID, AFTER JACOB
BLAKE.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN
FROM THE LEAGUE AND WITH THE
PLAYERS IS THAT THEY ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
ECONOMICS OF THIS CHALLENGE.
>> THINK ABOUT IT.
THINK ABOUT HOW MANY JOBS ALL OF
US HIRE DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
OFFICER.
ALL OF US HIRED SOMEBODY TO DEAL
WITH THIS ISSUES IN BIG
COMPANIES, SMALL COMPANIES,
ORGANIZATIONS EVERYWHERE.
LOTS OF CEOs AND LOTS OF PEOPLE
CAME OUT AND THEY TALKED ABOUT
IT AND SAID THEY WERE GREAT TO
DO SO MANY THINGS.
I THINK AS WE GO ON IN LIFE, WE
HAVE TO KEEP GIVING UP WHAT
YOU'RE NEEDING.
>> I'VE SEEN A LOT OF LIP
SERVICE.
I'VE HEARD A LOT OF PEOPLE
COMMIT TO DOING THE RIGHT THING
AND THERE WAS AN ARTICLE THAT
CAME OUT SAYING THAT VERY FEW
COMPANIES THAT MADE FUNDING
COMMITMENTS AROUND GEORGE
FLOYD'S MURDER, VERY FEW OF THEM
HAVE ACTED UPON THOSE THINGS.
>> SOME OF IT WAS PERFORMANCE.
SOME OF IT, YOU KNOW, JUST FOR,
YOU KNOW, THE SAKE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA.
AND, YOU KNOW, GIVING SOMEBODY
$50,000, WE WILL TAKE THE MONEY
BUT GIVING SOMEBODY $50,000 FOR
NOT CHANGING YOUR CORPORATE
CULTURE IS NOT WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
I HOPE THAT A LOT OF THESE
CORPORATIONS ARE DOING THE WORK
FROM WITHIN THEIR BUILDING.
>> THAT IS FIRST.
YOU KNOW?
NOT JUST HAVING THE ILLUSION OF
INCLUSION, BUT PROMOTING DIVERSE
VOICES AROUND THEM.
>> I HAVE SEEN SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN LARGE COMPANIES AND
CORPORATIONS, YOU KNOW, MAKING
SURE THAT THEY ALLOCATE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNTS OF ONE THING
AND VARIOUS OTHER THINGS, BUT
I'VE ALSO SEEN INTERNALLY HOW
THEY HAVE HAD DISCUSSIONS ON HOW
TO CREATE A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
AND AN EFFECTIVE CHANGE, WHETHER
IT BE IN THEIR HIRING PRACTICES,
WHETHER IT BEING IN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES HAVE BEEN.
>> THE UNFORTUNATE TRUTH IS THAT
WE DON'T TEND TO LEARN FROM OUR
WINS.
WE LEARN FROM OUR LOSSES.
AND IT IS SO SAD THAT IT'S OF
GEORGE FLOYD'S LIFE IN THAT
VIDEO TO CHANGE HEARTS AND
MINDS, AND IT'S EVEN MORE SAD
THAT IT HASN'T CHANGED SOME
HEARTS AND MINDS.
>> WHAT I THINK 2020 DID WAS
GIVE US CLEAR VISION INTO ALL OF
THE MANY CHALLENGES THE COUNTRY
FACES.
I THINK THAT 2021 INVITES US TO
REMEMBER TO SEE CLEARLY EVEN ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE TRAGEDY
KNOWING FULL WELL THAT THOSE
TRAGEDIES STILL EXIST.
>> WHAT I'VE TAKEN FROM THIS
REALLY DIFFICULT HARD YEAR HAS
TRULY BEEN INSPIRATIONAL AND
SAD.
THE SAD PART IS THE DEATHS THAT
WE HAVE EXPERIENCED BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC.
THE RACIAL UNREST THAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED HISTORICALLY.
THE INSPIRATIONAL PART IS THERE
IS A GENERATION AND A
WILLINGNESS TO SAY, HEY, WE ARE
GOING TO GET BETTER, WE ARE
GOING TO FIX IT.
>> OVER THE LAST YEAR, I THINK
THE LESSONS LEARNED ARE THAT NO
MATTER WHAT, SOMETHING IS GOING
TO HAPPEN, WHETHER A PLANE IS
CRASHING IN A BUILDING, GREAT
RECESSIONS, DOT COM, OR BUBBLE
CRASHES OR CORONAVIRUS.
HOW DO YOU GET PREPARED FOR THE
UNKNOWN IS BY CONSTANTLY EDUCATE
YOURSELF AND CONSTANTLY TRYING
TO PIVOT YOURSELF AROUND
LIKE-MINDED PEOPLE WHO ARE ALSO
TRITE EDUCATING THEMSELVES.
>> YOU SEE THE RISING UP AND
THEY ARE NOT JADED BUT HOPEFUL
AND LOOKING AT THIS COUNTRY AND
SAYING THIS IS WHAT I'M
INHERITING AND I DON'T WANT
THIS.
I WANT BETTER.
I'M CHOOSING BETTER.
I'M CHOOSING MORE.
AND SO I THINK, YOU KNOW, WHAT
HAS BEEN HOPEFUL IS LIKE IT'S
OKAY, WHAT HAVE I LEARNED?
HOW CAN WE HELP EMPOWER THIS
GENERATION TO BE WHAT WE NEED
THEM TO BE?
>> I THINK WE NEED TO GO BACK,
YOU KNOW, TO THAT FIRST TIME WE
WERE BORN AND WE HAVE A PURE
HEART, AND WE TAKE EVERYBODY
INTO OUR HEART, INTO OUR SPACE,
YOU KNOW, A BLANK SLATE.
WE REMEMBER HIM EVERY DAY, NOT
JUST TODAY IN THE ONE YEAR
REMEMBRANCE.
>> WE MADE A GREAT DEAL OF
PROGRESS IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF ANYONE TELLS YOU THAT WE
HAVEN'T, THEY ARE LYING.
AND NOTHING ABOUT THIS COUNTRY
IS IRREDEEMABLE.
BUT WE MUST DECONSTRUCT A LOT OF
THE SYSTEMS OR IMPRESSION THAT
WE HAVE AND REIMAGINE WHAT THEY
LOOK LIKE.
SO THAT IS MY GOAL, TO REIMAGINE
WHAT